i now make holiday wreaths out of hot
dogs and tortillas
[Music]
my favorite christmas memory
um well one of them is i had the
privilege of getting to visit a lot of
um
uh kids in various hospitals in new york
city on christmas day and i was able to
deliver i think it was playstations um
and hand them out that was really
awesome and i got to meet a lot of
incredible new york families
and very strong brave and hilarious kids
who were unfortunately celebrating their
christmas in a hospital but still
full of christmas spirit so that was a
good memory that i had
one of my most meaningful holiday
memories is from performing in new york
being on stage in that city on broadway
or off-broadway you're part of the
entertainment for people when they bring
their families to the city so you don't
get to have your own christmas so much
you're a part of you you're more like
it's like christmas in service
but um because that reason you band
together with the cast backstage and
it's a really special time
my favorite holiday memories is we were
snowed in one christmas so we couldn't
get out so our christmas dinner
was whatever my mom had in the fridge so
she made hot dog and green bean pizzas
maybe you've heard of it we had tomato
sauce on a tortilla and she cut little
wedges of the hot dogs on it and used
frozen green beans and that was our
christmas
dinner and it made us laugh and also i
kind of liked it
not against a hot dog pizza don't knock
it till you try it
so i now make holiday wreaths out of hot
dogs and tortillas
i was thinking the other day when i used
to help my
little cousin
put out food for the reindeer i guess i
heard different stories about how
reindeer like carrots they're like oats
apparently
what else was there i think there was
glitter in there which i guess glitter
doesn't harm reindeer i don't know
but i've always been a kid at heart
and i think that
just to be able to do things like that
and really let yourself
feel free and to be a kid again
at christmas is the best
best thing about christmas i think is
just
to find that sense of wonder and joy in
life and that's what i love about
[Music]
you